in the last week in the uk we have
seen 37 258
cases of coronavirus on average each day
the nhs is under intense pressure
across all parts of the country with 37
899 people in uk hospitals
with covid19 and that includes 4076
people on ventilators
sadly today 592
more deaths were reported and we must
never forget the real impact of this
disease
the loved ones that we've lost
grandparents parents
friends colleagues we grieve for each
one
thankfully there are early signs that
the actions that we're taking
are working the rise in the number of
cases is slowing and
falling in some parts of the country
like london
and scotland at the same time the number
of vaccinations is going up
like many of you i've been talking to
members of my family
who've just had the call to be
vaccinated it's a really
emotional moment when people get
vaccinated it means so much to people
because this vaccine brings safety
to that individual and it marks the
route out of for
us all from this pandemic and i'm
very proud to be able to tell you that
as of last night we have vaccinated
78.7 percent of all over 80s
that's almost four in five of everyone
age
over 80. and i'm delighted that you can
see from these figures that there's so
much enthusiasm
for vaccination amongst the over 80s
because octogenarians know what
scientists know
which is that the vaccine saves lives
as of today 6.6 million have now
received a vaccine against covid19
that's more than one in nine
of the adult population on saturday
alone we gave
nearly half a million jabs and
in the last week two and a half million
people
have been vaccinated across the uk
there's a rate of more than 250 people a
minute